those of us who spent like 30 years in
the gay rights movement as it were
our core objective was to remind people
a few things and this is this is what we
kind of we did in the in the 80s and 90s
really we said we just want to be like
you
we don't want to change your life in any
way maybe you'll be a little
uncomfortable because we're around but
you know can't help that
um we're not going to make you change
your pronouns we're not going to make
you do anything different at your
marriages we're going to not gonna if we
join the military we're gonna you know
we're just gonna be treated the same as
everyone else and all of this will be
fine and everyone was sort of cool after
a while you know there was some initial
hostility and panic and fear and then it
slowly and now we have 70 support for
those things
what we did was
emphasize what we have in common with
everyone else
not what sets us apart in other words
what we were doing was a Universalist
human experiment what they're doing is a
very particularist identity based
uh defense of it which appeals to no one
because it it's not even asking anybody
to agree or disagree it's demanding it's
demanding obedience because again this
comes down to philosophically
if you believe in power if you believe
in truth they don't believe in truth
they don't believe there's any stable
truth let alone about biology or
anything else
um
so the only way they can do this is by
the exercise of raw power which is
either just enforcing things and
demanding it like the American Medical
Association is now doing
um or demanding that you use certain
pronouns or not or smearing and
targeting and demonizing anybody who
speaks up against not saying their
arguments are wrong because this isn't
this but spanning God knows how much
time and energy saying that someone like
JK Rowling is somehow an evil human
being when it's quite obvious to any
sane person that she is not but that's
what they do because they don't have
the muscles for argument they do not
actually want to stress what they have
in common with everyone else it is a
kind of adolescent temper tantrum that
has always been there within gay
politics within the queer movement and
which many of us in the 80s and 90s were
like if we carry on like this we're not
going to get even basic protections or
even basic respect to many of us who
were not identifying that way who was
the last thing on earth I would call
myself is queer uh uh it felt as if the
movement didn't really exist and we came
in and the movement actually did shift
and it did succeed
but then we succeeded and we left
because I'll go I thought well I'm
concerned once he got a basic rights our
job now is to get on with our [__]
lives and actually do something with
them and so that this stuff is not
obsessing it's about going forward it's
not about obsessing about who you are
um and uh
so we quit and then they get to Define
it all
and the trans people come in and the
queer Theory people come in who are
always there but were kept somewhat at
Bay
and they just took over and they've
gotten rid of the entire older
establishment of the gay rights
organizations they are the most militant
they are the least Democratic they are
the most authoritarian and they
borderline violence and offensive
their discourse if you compare our
arguments to marriage equality with
their vicious insults just the way they
just say things like [__] you into
people's faces in a demo there are other
ways of demonstrating you know than
saying [__] off or I want you to suck my
[__] dick
we didn't we didn't say that when we
were asking for the right dimensions
it's also defeating and it's it's it's
done a lot to put back
along with this [__] words that we
have to use like lgbtqia plot and and
gender affirming care all this [__]
and I think there are a lot of people
who who just feel like they've been this
has been imposed on them and [__] you
and it's the word Queer as well and I'm
glad you brought it up because so a lot
of my family from Venezuela and I have
there's a saying in my my family are
called LA palisas and there's a saying
enough police says that you're either
ugly or you're gay right those are the
two choices so I grew up with a lot of
gay men who were closeted in Latin
America and seen what they had to go
through and now this I actually find it
it actually pisses me off when people go
I'm queer and they just it's just an
identity it's just something to play
with and I'm like it's identity slumming
that's what I call it it's it's like Sue
I'm so cool I'm queer now it's like I
was some some dude on Twitter a couple
of years back I think which is like this
nice middle-aged guy with a nice wife
and two kids and a little picture of him
on Twitter and he's like some academic
and he just said this I just decided a
day that I needed on Twitter to come out
as queer
I'm queer now and I just tweeted back no
you're not
if but if you are if that is that's the
point the point of the left is to take
queer and expand it Beyond homosexual
well first of all to co-opt every
homosexual into it with how [__] dare
they
suddenly decide that because they they
they're the lobby group that controls
the New York Times The Washington Post
and sends them guides to the words they
use
that suddenly we have the word queer
used in the New York Times ubiquitously
as simply a neutral descriptor of gay
people
again in position power not persuasion
in any way and then they lie that this
has happened spontaneously and
organically no it hasn't I mean there's
a bunch of Ivy League gays have suddenly
decided to call themselves that uh
uh so
I don't think it's going to succeed I
think it's gonna
hurt actually and I think I think uh and
I think that's gonna be even a lot of
trans kids in red States and gay kids in
blue states are going to suffer from the
fact we either have All or Nothing in
terms of treatment of of children with
gender dysphoria for me
the one point I want to make is this on
that question is that if you tell a
three or four-year-old boy
who might be feeling maybe I'm not like
the other boys I like this I like
playing Barbie I like reading I like I
don't like playing rugby or whatever if
you tell them you can be a boy or a girl
or both or neither
or something else entirely
uh and they're told this is a choice for
them
it is quite possible
that a young gay boy will internalize
that is the idea that I really should be
a girl
and that breaks my heart it breaks my
heart
because everything we try to do which
was to tell gay boys you do not have to
deny your maleness to be gay you don't
have to renounce your sex to be gay
uh is being undone
and the stereotypical
models and behaviors that are being fed
into the minds of these children well
what we fought against
uh and the impact on gay kids
people don't talk about they always talk
about trans but many of them are not
trans many of them are gay and Confused
um and most the vast majority of kids we
generate dysphoria we all know resolve
it in puberty and go on to be gay the
question for gay people is how many of
us are being
uh siphoned off that path by well meant
but overly invasive engineering of these
kids before they're really capable of
making these proper decisions for
themselves this is about gay kids
that's why they insist on lgbtqa that's
where they take all these very different
experiences and and and and identities
and mash them all into this queer thing
so they can prevent these tensions from
being aired
well they will be aired
um but what's happened is that because
of tribalism
the vast majority of gay men are going
to shut up
they can't support the scientists they
can't support these right Wingers they
can't support the Republicans they can't
support the religious right therefore
they're fine
thank you